SHANNON: She's a fourth
generation Argentine vintner
and an emergency physician in
San Francisco at UCSF and CPMC
Children's Hospital.
She grew up in Argentina during
the military dictatorship,
finished high school
in the East Bay,
and studied biology at Harvard
and medicine at Stanford.
Today, she's managing director
of her family winery, Bodega
Catena Zapata, and makes
her own wines in Argentina
under the Luca label, and is a
practicing emergency physician
in San Francisco
at CPMC and UCSF.
She's the author of "Vino
Argentino, an Insider's Guide
to Wines and the Wine
Country of Argentina,"
which was published by Chronicle
Books at the end of 2010.
It's the first
English language book
about Argentine food and wine.
With that, I'll turn
it over to Laura.
LAURA CATENA: Thank
you very much, Shannon.
I think I'm speaking with this.
I feel like I don't
to say anything now,
but thank you very much.
Shannon.
So today we're going to talk
a little bit about my book,
"Vino Argentino," about
Argentina, my country, my wine
region, Mendoza, a
little bit about Malbec,
a little bit about my
family's 100-year-old history
making wine, and also I'll share
a bit of my personal story.
These are the main principles
that we live by at our winery.
Compete with the best.
Although we are in a
developing country,
we try to make
wines that can stand
with the best of the world.
Be academic.
When we don't know something,
we study, we do research,
and we're humble about what we
know and what we don't know.
And believe fiercely
in what we do,
so that others will
also believe in us.
So this is my father,
Nicolas Catena and my uncle,
Jorge and my tia, Silvia.
My father grew up in a very
tiny village in Mendoza.
And at the age of
five, he started
working in the vineyard
with his father.
At the age of five, my kids were
working on their PlayStation
skills, like probably
some of you were.
This is my great-grandfather,
Nicola Catena,
that came to Argentina
from Italy in 1898
with the dream of planting
a vineyard of his own.
I imagine some of you, your
parents, your grandparents,
immigrated to the United
States with great dreams.
And this is my grandmother,
Angelica Zapata.
We have a vineyard and
a wine named after her.
And unfortunately,
I never met her
because she died in a car
accident when my father was 18.
But she is a very important
part of our family folklore.
She was the headmaster
of the local school.
And she was a very tough
mother, according to my father.
And she believed
that education was
the way to progress and
to improving our society.
And she was known to go
get kids at their home
if they missed school.
Because many times, the
parents would keep them at home
so that they would work.
And she would actually
drive to the house,
sometimes even pay the parents
and bring the kid to school.
And my father tells a story of
when he was 18 years old, right
before she died, and
he went to her saying
that he wanted to study
physics, and said to her,
what should I do with
a degree in physics?
And she said, you should
try to win the Nobel Prize.
And maybe you guys talk
about winning the Nobel Prize
at Google, but he was a child
in a very small village.
And to have this
sort of expectation
explains a lot of
what happened after.
And it also explains possibly
some of my childhood traumas.
So this is actually
a framed copy
of a review from Robert
Parker's, the wine advocate.
Does anybody know--
does everybody
know who is Robert Parker?
So he's this very
famous wine reviewer.
And he gave one of our
wines 98 plus points.
And this was the first time
that an Argentine wine,
or a South American
wine actually,
had received such a high rating.
So I put it in a frame
for my winemaker.
And the next day,
I came over and I
saw that he'd crossed
it off and he said,
quiero cien, which
means, I want 100.
And at first I thought well,
this guy's a little ungrateful.
And then I thought,
you know, no.
This is the kind of
person that will actually
make 100 point wine.
Because he won't be happy
until he achieves the top.
So Argentina is an
amazing country.
Those of you who've been
there or who were born there,
know what a beautiful
place it is.
We have monkeys in
the north, penguins
in the south, beautiful
plains with cattle.
We are one of the
largest producers
of soybean in the world.
We have tango.
We're my tango dancer?
We have such incredible
culture there.
But it's also a country
with an incredible economic
instability.
So during my childhood, this
is what inflation looked like.
So imagine living
in a country where
you have 30, 40, 50,
3,000% inflation.
And one thing I remember as
a child is that you always
spent your money,
because you never
knew how much it would
be worth a week later.
And believe me,
it's very difficult.
Currently, the inflation
rate is about 30%.
And it's not easy to do
business in this environment.
And it's also a
country where there's
been a lot of political turmoil.
During my childhood, there
were two military coups.
And more recently in 2001,
we had riots in the streets.
And we had five
presidents in one week.
These are all the presidents.
We currently have
a female president.
So in the late
'70s, we were living
in a militarized country.
And my father had to negotiate
the release of my uncle
by kidnappers.
He had been kept in
a closet for a week.
And my brother and
I had been sent
to a boarding school
in the countryside.
And it wasn't like the
fancy boarding schools
that you have here.
It was really in a village
in the countryside.
And when I was 10
years old-- I was
five when I started--
when I was 10 years old,
I was once sitting
in a classroom
and some guys in big
military gear kicked the door
and pointed guns at us.
And the reason
they were there was
because they thought that
there were [INAUDIBLE], which
is our word for terrorist,
hiding in our school.
And our school was closed down.
We came back to Buenos Aires.
And at that time,
my father decided
to take a sabbatical
in Berkeley.
And the one thing I
wanted to talk about,
and recently I was reading
a book called "I Am Malala."
I don't if any of
you have read it.
Anybody here read "I Am Malala?"
It's a book about this
young girl in Pakistan
who is shot by the Taliban.
And she has this horrible
story of how she's shot.
But most of the book is
this joyful celebration
of living in this country where
there's bombs and shootings.
But she celebrates her life
with family and friends.
And actually, when my father
said we were leaving Argentina,
I was very upset, because
I was very happy there,
despite all the
things are happening.
But I was dragged to Berkeley.
And there's a picture of
our family in Berkeley.
This is my father holding my
baby sister who was born there,
my mother, myself, and
my older brother who
went off to college.
And my father was a visiting
scholar at UC Berkeley.
But more importantly,
what he learned
about was this incredible
revolution that
was going on in the Napa Valley.
These crazy
Californians were saying
that they were going to make
wines in California that
could compete with
the best French wines.
And I just want to take a little
survey of the room, who here
thinks that California
can make wine that's
as good as the
best French wines?
Can we see some arms?
OK.
Who thinks, and
you guys, there's
no military regime at
Google, I understand.
Who here thinks that the
top French wines are still
the best in the world?
Oh, yeah.
We got one.
Excellent.
[INAUDIBLE]
Good for you.
So anyhow, the Californians
have done a good job
at convincing people.
But at that time, for my father
to hear this was revolutionary.
Because he had grown up
in a world where you never
challenged the French, where
they dominated fine wine,
and where he could never
imagine that somebody
could compete with them.
And then he heard about
the Judgment of Paris.
Have any of you seen the
movie "Bottle Shock?"
So basically, this was a tasting
ran by an English man, Steven
Spurrier, right here, with
a bunch of French judges,
where they compared--
it was in 1976-- they
compared California wine
against French wine.
Does anybody know
who won the tasting?
Anybody?
?
Yes?
Chateau Montelena for
the chardonnay and Stag's
Leap for the Cabernet Sauvignon.
And actually, the
French people are still
denying that this
tasting ever happened.
But the Americans were
smart and made a movie.
So that proves everything.
So my father went
back to Argentina.
And he said, if the
Californians can do it,
why not me in Argentina.
And this is just a side line.
While my father was planning
this revolution in Argentina,
I was actually perfecting
the Berkeley hippie look.
I thought that was pretty good.
I had a good time in Berkeley.
Anybody here live in Berkeley?
You guys?
Yeah?
It's a great place.
So why was what my father was
trying to do so difficult?
At that time, South
America was equivalent
with cheap Chilean wine.
And you guys seem kind
of young, so you may not
have been drinking wine.
This is the mid '80s.
And at that time, South
America was cheap wine.
And most people in
Argentina were saying,
we need to do what
Chile's doing.
They're doing very well with it.
We should go along with
what they're doing.
And when my father
said to his colleagues,
I want to make these
wines that can stand
with the best of the world,
they said first of all,
we don't know if it's possible.
But even if you
made those wines,
no one will believe
that they're good.
But my father was
not easily dissuaded.
And I want to talk a
little bit about what
I call the academic approach.
This is actually my father
and my sister, Adrianna,
she was the baby in
the Berkeley picture.
She's getting a PhD in medieval
history at Oxford University.
And I was in the car with my
sister, telling her, you know,
I think it's funny when
dad talks about your thesis
as if he knows as much
as you do about it.
And my sister said, well he
actually knows more than I do.
And my father is the kind of
person that loves to learn.
And any time he sets his mind
to learning something new,
he does.
And actually here, my sister's
put him to work at the archives
in [INAUDIBLE], studying
medieval Spanish history.
So this kind of
academic approach
is what he applied
to figuring out
how to make these
wines in Argentina.
And the first thing
he did was hire
some well-known consultants.
And his first
consultant was a guy
from California
named Paul Hobbs.
Has anybody had
Paul Hobb's wines?
Yeah.
Yeah, so he's a very
talented winemaker.
He had made wine in France.
He was making wine
in California.
And when he came
to Argentina, we
worked on how could
we go from the bottom
up to make these wines.
And the way wines
were being made
in Argentina at that
time was in what
we call the Italian
oxidative method.
And what we would do is
we would press the grapes.
And we would put them in these
huge old French oak barriques.
And the wines would
receive oxygen.
And what happens when
a wine gets oxygen
is that it loses its
characteristics, its flavors.
So imagine that you
leave a bottle out
on the countertop for five days.
You drink it.
It doesn't taste like anything.
Everything tastes the same.
And that's how wine
was being made.
So he realized that he
had to change everything
from the vineyard, studying the
terroir, the soil, the climate,
and the winery, we were the
first to bring to Argentina
small French oak barriques,
and also the plant sources.
So if you-- does anybody
have a little vineyard
in their backyard here?
There you go.
So if you want to
plant your vineyard,
you go to a vine nursery
and you buy some plants.
And you ask for A quality
plants, B quality plants,
C quality plants.
A quality is small
production high quality.
C quality is high yielding,
maybe not as interesting.
So what my father
did is he started
bringing some of these top
level, high quality, plant
selections to Argentina
for the first time.
And I'm going to explain
to you in a minute why
I'm having a light
saber fight here.
But first of all, I want to
talk about Jacques Luton who
is Darth Vader here, who
was our French consultant.
And has anybody had any of
the Luton wines from France?
So has anybody had Chavel Blanc?
So Chavel Blanc is
a very famous wine.
And Jacques's cousin is the
winemaker at Chavel Blanc.
And they're this very well
known Bourdeaux family
that make wine.
And my father, when I was
still at Harvard undergrad,
invited me to go with him
to France as his translator.
And we went to see Jacques.
And we brought a bottle of
some Cabernet Sauvignon,
this is in the late '80s,
of some Cabernet Sauvignon
from one of the traditional
areas in Argentina in the east.
And we brought this
bottle of wine.
And we poured it for him.
I remember we were in
this very fancy chateau.
I was so impressed
by everything.
And he said, Nicola [INAUDIBLE].
This is a very nice
Cabernet Sauvignon.
Like one from the [INAUDIBLE].
And I heard this, and I thought
oh, that sounds wonderful.
And then my father
was very serious.
And I said, what's going on.
And he said this is
the worst insult.
This would be like
somebody saying
this tastes like a
very nice Cabernet
from the Central Valley.
So anyhow, so we have
this opportunity.
Jacques and I were
both invited to what
was called the Jedi Tour
by our importer in Canada.
And I said, let's have some fun.
Let's have a light saber fight.
And I said, but I
have to kill you
at the end in revenge for
what you said to us, to my dad
and I. Because now he
thinks we make great wine.
But anyhow, the main concept
that came from Jacques
was about cool climate.
And this could have
been a death sentence.
Because maybe we didn't
have any cool climate.
But we were fortunate
that as you go up
towards the mountains, it gets
colder and colder and colder.
So we actually had a
location with cooler climate
within our region.
So this is my grandfather,
who I call Nonno.
That's what you call your
grandfather in Italian.
And the slide is
named Why Malbec?
So my grandfather used to do to
France and Italy, and come back
and say to my dad,
Nicolas, you're
paying way too much attention
to Cabernet Sauvignon
and chardonnay.
The greatest variety
that we have is Malbec.
And my father wasn't
sure, because most
of the Malbecs he tasted back
then weren't that interesting.
But then in the late '80s,
my grandfather passed away
and my dad got a little
sentimental, said you know,
I got to try this.
It got to do this for my father.
And the interesting thing
when I was working on my book,
I did a lot of
research on Malbec.
And actually, Malbec was one of
the most prestigious varieties
in France in the Middle Ages
and in the 19th century.
In the Middle Ages, it
was called the black wine.
And actually it was drank
and the wedding of Eleanor
of Acquitaine and also
is famous in the court
of Peter the Great.
And then in Bordeaux, in
the 19th century, 40 to 60%
of the first growths,
all these famous wines,
first, second, third growth,
the grand crus from France
had Malbec in them.
But the French don't
like to talk about it.
Because now they replace
the Malbec with Merlot,
so they don't want to
make the Malbec famous.
But this was a variety with a
very good pedigree in quality
and also in ageability.
So this is the
Adrianna Vineyard,
named after my sister.
And so what my
father did at first
was to study the
climate and the soil.
And he put weather
stations all over Mendoza.
This took about 10 years
to do all this research.
And he found this
place in Gualtallary
in a place called Tupungato.
Have you heard of
the Uco Valley?
So the Uco Valley is where
some very high quality
wines come in Argentina.
And this was a vineyard.
Kelsey, your mother's
vineyard's in the Uco Valley.
Yeah, we have somebody
with a vineyard
in the family in the Uco valley.
So he went to this place.
He put these weather stations .
And this place was
as cold as Burgundy.
Has anybody here
been to Burgundy?
A few people, yeah.
So Burgundy, you would never
ever plant Malbec in Burgundy.
Because Malbec is
a Bordeaux variety.
And it would be too cold.
But my father thought,
hey it's cold.
But it's very sunny.
So Malbec might ripen there.
And it did.
And you're going to get to
taste some of the Malbec
from Adrianna.
So he planted this
vineyard despite the fact
that all his
viticulturalists said
grapes will never ripen here.
But they did.
And then the next
thing that he had
to work on what the
plant selection.
Because you could go to the
divine nurseries in France
and get fantastic cuttings
for Cabernet or chardonnay.
But you couldn't get
good quality Malbec.
So he went to our
oldest vineyard
which is named Angelica
after my grandmother.
And he made a selection
of 145 different plans.
And one important thing
to know about vines
is that although
in the wild, they
would reproduce by
seeds, if you were
to plant the seed of
a grape, of Cabernet,
the new plant would
not be Cabernet.
It would create a
different variety.
So if you want to plant
a Cabernet vineyard,
you actually use the
cuttings after pruning.
And a cutting from
one plant will
make another plant that's
exact to the mother plant.
And so he made a selection of
145 plants and studied them.
And then, we call these
the Catena cuttings,
and we plant these cuttings
in all our vineyards.
And this is just to
show you how different
the grapes can be from
four different cuttings.
So they're completely different.
And they have completely
different flavors.
But they are all Malbec.
So this is my
mother, Elena Catena.
So 10 years of research, we
now go from the early '80s
to the late '80s, I
think it was about '91.
And my father has made some
wines, Cabernet, chardonnay,
Malbec, that the consultants,
people who come down
to the winery say, wow, you've
hit a great level of quality.
But he has a big problem, which
is that he's a total geek.
And he likes to spend time
in a library or alone.
There might be some of you
like that, but maybe not.
And he realizes that he
is not the right person
to go out to the world
and tell our story.
And my mom was actually
running a high tech
company in Argentina back then.
And she went back actually to
running her high tech company.
That's what she does now.
But so my dad asked my mom
if she would go to the US
and to Europe and
present our wines.
And just to tell you a little
bit about my mom's personality,
everybody in their
family has the parent
that arrives early to the
airport and the one that
arrives late, right.
And so obviously my dad
arrives about five hours early,
and my mom 30 minutes earlier.
And so one time we were running
to the gate with my brother,
my mother, and I. And
we get to the gate.
And there is the pilot.
And the plane is pulling off.
And my mom drops to her
knees and starts praying.
And the guy comes back.
And we get on the plane.
So my mom told me how this
went, her trip to the US.
She said, Laurita,
that's what she calls me,
I went to the store.
I show them our wine.
They said, I will not by an
Argentenian wine for $20.
And I said, OK, Give me.
What is your best
wine in the store?
And they would pull some wine.
I would buy it.
I would say, let's
taste it blind.
And we always won the
blind competition.
So my mother sold
one bottle at a time.
And we will always
be grateful to her,
because I don't think that
anybody else in our family
could have done this.
So the New York Wine Experience.
This is why I'm here today.
Because I went to
medical school.
I had absolutely no intention
of ever working for my family.
But it was the '90s.
I had just finished
med school at Stanford.
I was doing my residency
in emergency medicine.
And my dad called
me and said, we've
been invited to this
very prestigious thing.
Has anybody been to the
New York Wine Experience?
Oh, you have been.
Great.
So the New York Wine Experience
is this amazing tasting
where the Wine
Spectator invites some
of the top winers of the world.
It's kind of expensive.
But you get to taste wines.
Did you not think it was
incredible-- the wines?
You get to taste wines that you
would never be able to taste.
It would take you years to
go visit all those places
and to get that kind of quality.
You get old vintages from some
of the best wines in France,
and Italy, and all
over the world.
So we were invited.
We were the first
Argentine winery
to be invited to this tasting.
And so I'm standing
in my little booth.
And I'm watching these
big crowds standing
behind the Italian, the
Californian, the French.
And this is what it
looked like at my stand.
So people and walk by.
They'd kind of look over me
because I have heels now,
but normally I'm pretty short.
And so they would see Catena.
They would see Argentina.
And they would make
no eye contact.
They'd keep on walking.
And what really pissed me off is
that some people would actually
spit at my spittoon
somebody else's wine.
And then they'd move on.
So I had very few people
coming to my stand.
And it made me so angry.
So the minute I got back to
California, I called my dad.
And I said, I want in.
I'm coming to work with you.
I want to go to the winery.
I want to go to the vineyards.
I want to help you
sell the wines.
Because I realized that
he needed some major help,
that what he was trying
to do was so difficult.
This is important.
So I started
working with my dad.
And I knew a lot
about wine tasting.
And I tasted some great wines.
But I knew very little
of the wine lingo.
And I didn't really know which
varieties were from where.
And this is actually one of
the first books that I read.
And probably none of
you have read this book.
But it's a great book.
I highly recommend
it, especially
if you've tasted a lot
but you kind of forget,
oh what's the grape
from Piedmont?
And what's the grape
from this place?
You read this book.
And you actually know
more than most winemakers
about some of the
basics about wine.
So I highly recommend it.
So when I went back, I realized
that all these consultants
were giving us advice
about how to make
great wine in other
parts of the world.
But our region was
completely different.
There is no other region in the
world as high as our region.
And also, they didn't know a
lot about Malbec wine making.
In fact, most of us would
tell us to make Malbec the way
you make Cabernet.
And actually, you need to treat
Malbec totally differently.
And they would also give
us advice like, you know,
in order to remove
green flavors,
you need to remove all
the leaves from the vines.
And actually, if you remove all
the leaves at high altitude,
there's so much sunlight that
you get burning of the grapes.
And you get pruney flavors.
And that's not what you want.
So I realized that
we were going to have
to do our own research if we
wanted to improve quality.
And that's why I founded
the Catena Institute that
does over 1,000
microvinifications per year.
And we study everything
about our climate,
high altitude, Malbec.
And also we study new
varieties, new regions,
sort of whatever
we think is fun.
This is one of the
studies that we did.
So this is the Angelica
vineyard at 2,700 elevation,
La Piramide,
Adrianna, the vineyard
you saw the picture of,
5,000 feet elevation.
You can see the
temperature is a lot lower.
You go from 15, average
15 Celsius, to 12.
This in viticulture
is a huge difference.
And the sun is a
lot more intense.
And we found that these
grapes at high altitude,
and these are all the same
plant selections of Malbec,
had more than twice the amount
of tannins in the skins.
And tannins are what give
you a flavor and ageability.
So we found that there was a
very big impact from altitude
on great quality and also on
the kind of flavors we got.
And this is a group
of our researchers.
They're measuring
photosynthesis in the plants.
And I imagine you think that
wine research is, you just walk
around with a glass
of wine and have fun.
But actually, it's
pretty hard work.
And there's a lot of sun.
But it's still really fun.
And this is a recent article
that we published about Malbec
in "The American Journal of the
Viticulture and Technology."
And this made me really proud.
This professor at
Davis said that it
was the largest of its
magnitude ever undertaken
of a single variety in multiple
countries and hemispheres.
And I was very proud
that our institute
was able to publish in probably
the most reputable journal
and our industry.
And this research
was done by our head
of research, Fernando Buscema.
OK, so a little Argentina facts.
So does anybody
know who this is?
Messi, muy bien.
Goal!
OK.
So Lionel Messi, four times
number one soccer player
in the world.
I was going to say futbol
but here it's soccer.
So Lionel Messi.
And then, OK.
I'm telling you who that is.
That's Manu Ginobili.
Do you know who he plays for?
It's on his t-shirt.
The San Antonio Spurs.
So one fun fact is
that Argentina-- and he
was part of the team-- won the
Olympics in basketball in 2004.
Did anybody know this?
And they actually
beat the US team.
But don't feel too
bad, because we
took only two gold that year.
And you guys took 36.
And the US has a one the
basketball Olympics, men's 14
times and the women's seven.
And we've only won it once.
But I thought I'd share
this fun fact, because I'm
really proud of these
two guys because they
are at the top of their game.
And they're trying
to do in their field
the same thing that we're doing.
And it's very cool
that they're Argentine.
And I think that they both drink
Catena wines, I've been told.
So that's another
plus for them too.
This is a map of our
Adrianna vineyard.
And it would probably take
me about an hour or two
to explain this map.
But I want to tell you a story.
About 15 years ago, I was
at the Adrianna vineyard
up there, almost
5,000 feet elevation.
And I was talking to the
viticulturist in charge.
And I was seeing that there
was some areas of the vineyard
that some browning that
didn't look so good.
And I said, hey, what can we do
in these parts of the vineyard,
because this is the vineyard
are we getting our best quality.
And he said, you should take
a bulldozer to this vineyard.
You should take
all the vines out.
You should take all the
topsoil, mix it all up,
and put it back on.
Because there's too much
diversity in this vineyard.
And this really pissed
me off obviously,
because I'm thinking this
is our best vineyard.
What are you talking about?
But I kind of realized
talking to him
that we needed to go a lot
more micro in this vineyard,
that we needed to separate lots
and treat them all differently.
Not only in the vineyard,
but then in the winery.
And based on that, we actually
changed our whole approach
to dividing our vineyards and
harvesting at different times.
And this vineyard actually
this recent harvest
was harvested in
137 different lots.
There were all
harvested separately.
Each lot was treated separately
and vinified separately.
So that's why you see so many
marks and things on this map.
And although this viticulturist
is no longer with us,
I'm actually-- I
always remember him,
because he taught me something.
And this is just for you to see.
You could have these three
completely different kinds
of soils within this space.
These are calcareous soils.
They're also called
limestone soils.
You might have heard
in Burgundy they
have a lot of limestone soils.
And they're considered
very high quality.
We also like them
very much for Malbec.
This is a deep soil that
has a little bit of clay,
retains a little more
moisture, maybe a little better
for Cabernet which does
not like too much stress.
And this is a stony soil, which
we love for Malbec, because it
has excellent drainage and it
actually stresses the vine.
And Malbec does very well
with a little bit of stress.
We get great
quality with stress.
So this is our winemaker,
Alejandro Vigil.
And I love this guy.
He's been working
with us since 2002,
because he is, to me
the winemaker that I've
met that best mixes the art
and the science of wine making.
And we actually
hired him when he
was the head of
the soils division
at the local
agriculture institute.
And he first came in research.
But then I realized that he
had such an amazing palette
that he became our
head winemaker.
And he and I love
to taste together.
And watching him taste,
what I realize every time
is that there is no
chemical measurement that
can be better than
a good tongue.
Because if you measure acidity,
if you measure alcohol,
you can measure tannins,
there's all kinds of things
that you can measure.
But a good taster will
give you better information
about the quality of a wine that
any kind of chemical analysis.
And that's why I love
working with him, because he
has such an
extraordinary palate.
And this is a
tattoo that he has.
And I love the story
about this tattoo.
He was at a tasting in Brazil.
And he had been invited
to this collector's house.
Oh, yeah.
You're the Brazil guy.
Yeah.
OK, so he was invited
to this tasting.
And this guy was opening one
amazing bottle after another.
And then the next
thing he remembers
is he's in his
hotel room sleeping.
He wakes up.
And he's got this tattoo.
It says Malbec.
And fortunately, Juan
Cruz and not Rosita,
because Juan Cruz is his son.
So that was OK with
his wife, Maria.
But I love the story
about the tattoo.
So here we are,
aspiring to make wines
that can stand with
the best of the world.
And with the 1997 vintage of
the Nicolas Catena Zapata.
And that's a wine that
I named after my father.
It's a Cabernet Malbec.
That that's his favorite blend.
I thought we were ready.
And my father agreed, although
he kept on backing off,
that we were ready to do blind
tastings around the world,
comparing our wines to others.
And this is actually a tasting
that was published online.
We did this tasting in
London and look at the date.
So it was September 10, 2001.
So actually, none
of our winemakers
could get back home
back after the tasting.
But we did this tasting where we
compared to Latour, [INAUDIBLE]
Caymus special
selection, Opus One.
And we were mostly
hoping that we
wouldn't be last in the tasting.
But we actually came in first.
And people like
Jancis Robinson--
does anybody know who
Jancis Robinson is?
She's probably the most
famous female wine person.
She organized the tasting.
And there were many other
very good palates from England
there.
And we came in first.
There were three small tastings.
We came in first.
And the interesting
thing is that they
were supposed to write
which wine they thought
was which wine.
And nobody guessed that
our wine was our wine.
Because they could not imagine
that a wine from Argentina
would be that good.
And that was in 2001.
And this is a little review that
Robert Parker's "Wine Advocate"
that our importer prepared.
And it was basically
comparing average ratings
from 2004 to 2009.
These are some of
the top rated wines.
And Romanee-Conti, I've only
had it once, it's about $10,000
plus a bottle.
Has anybody here had it?
OK.
So you have to find some rich
person to share it with you.
That's-- or like my winemaker.
Go to some collector's house.
So we're right after.
And then you might know some of
these wines-- Harlan, Shafer,
Hillside Select,
Gaia, Chateaubriand.
So these are amazing reviews.
But the reality is
that people still
don't know about
the kind of quality
we can get in Argentina.
So I need you guys, all of
you here, to taste these wines
and talk about them.
Because we still have a lot of
work to do for our whole region
to show the kind of
quality we can make.
And this is Chateau Lafite.
And in 1998, the owners
of Chateau Lafite,
Eric de Rothschild, came to
our cantina, tasted our wines,
fell in love with our
Malbec and our Cabernet.
And we formed a partnership
with them that is called Caro.
Has anybody had this wine.
So it's a really--- oh, Shannon.
Very good.
So it's a great wine. it
also ages beautifully.
And the best thing
is that when I
go to Vinexpo, which
is the big wine fair.
Have you been?
Anybody?
So it's actually pretty boring.
Don't go to that.
But the New York Wine
Experience is worth it.
But anyhow, I get
to-- that's my hotel.
So that makes the
whole project worth it.
It's pretty fun.
So this is my father
when he received
the Decanter Man
of the Year Award.
And this award is kind of
like the lifetime achievement
that they give to
actors at the Oscars.
And he's also received a similar
award, Distinguished Service
Award in 2012, from
Wine Spectator.
He's received awards from Wine
Enthusiast, Der Feinschmecker.
And this'll be the
equivalent of standing
next to Sergey Brin, Larry
Page, Steve Jobs-- what's
the Tesla guy-- Elon
Musk, Mark Zuckerberg.
Although they'd be a lot
younger and no women.
I almost didn't
want to show this.
But next time we'll
get women on the slide.
But this is a big deal for us,
for a winery, for my father,
to receive this award.
And a really fun
thing was in 2013
when he went to receive this
award at Wine Spectator,
we went back and we had
long lines on our booth.
And then actually
at the gala event
where they give
the awards, we were
sitting at the head table with
Francis Ford Coppola and Angelo
Gaja.
And I was saying to my
dad, 20 years ago-- I mean,
there is no way I
would have predicted
sitting on this table.
We almost felt like
cheats or fakes,
that we were actually sitting
in that table with all
these people.
Because we would have
never pictured being there
or getting there.
So this book, "Vino
Argentino," and the reason I
wrote this book
was because I got
tired of going to taste
things and I'd ask people,
well when do you think
Argentina started making wine?
And they'd say 20 years ago.
And we've been making
wine in Argentina
since the 16th century.
We are the fifth largest
of wine in the world.
We have all these Italian
and Spanish immigrants
that came to Argentina.
We drink wine the way
the Italians, the French,
the Spanish, now the Americans.
Actually, America keeps on
moving up in wine consumption.
So this book has a
lot of information
about the wine country.
There are some recipes.
It also has a chapter
on Buenos Aires,
which restaurants to go to.
So I hope that you get it.
And you have a really
cheap price, by the way.
Because it's normally
sold for $25.
And apparently there's
a Google discount.
And you get it for $10.
I-- actually, my author
copies cost me $11.
So you have a really good deal.
So just to review the principles
that we live by at Catena.
Compete with the best.
We always aspire
to make wines that
stand with the
best of the world.
The academic-- if you
don't know something,
study it, research it, be
humble about what you know
and what you don't know.
Believe and make others believe.
Sometimes I'll tell
people at the winery,
find the Elena
Cartena in you, when
I think they need some guts.
And home is where the heart is.
That's a little more
of a personal note.
When I studied medicine,
I had this idea
that business people
were bad, that I
was going to be a doctor
because that was the way
to help people.
And sorry, because you
work for a business.
But I changed my mind.
And once I started
working with my dad
and I saw how the rural
communities were changing
because of wine, how people
now had gardens and had better
schools and had more wealth.
And also watching the people
I work, our winemakers,
who are so inspired
by our daily work
to make these great
Argentine wines,
I actually came
to the realization
that I have a much bigger
impact on the world
through my wine region.
And actually, the
work my father has
done in promoting the
whole region, not just
our own winery, that is probably
a lot more significant in terms
of a contribution that
what I do as a physician.
And so I have kind
of full circle
changed my mind
about how one can
make a contribution
to this world.
And this is just some of the
work that our foundation does.
It's named after-- that's
my grandmother, Angelica.
We support some of
the-- we're almost done,
guys-- three more slides.
We support some of the local
schools, some of the trade
schools, because
we feel it's very
important for the
traditional trades
to be maintained
in the countryside.
This is our head of research who
we sponsored to go to UC Davis
to study.
And this is our pyramid.
And the last slide.
So why we have a pyramid
on all our labels--
when my father was moving
the vineyards to the higher
altitude, he wanted to find
an architectural style that
would symbolize South America.
And so he didn't want to
make an Italian, or French,
or a Spanish style building.
And he was inspired
by the Mayans, who
were the most advanced
civilization of the Americas
in terms of astronomy, and
language, and mathematics.
And so he designed the winery in
the shape of the Mayan pyramid.
So thank you very much.
Any questions?
OK.
Well, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: It might
be a basic question.
But I'm a very big fan of
Carmeneres and Malbecs.
Why Carmenere never
makes to Argentina,
Malbecs never make to Chile?
LAURA CATENA: That's
a very good question.
Well, Malbec-- actually,
I don't know the answer
to the question of why they
were brought initially.
So Malbec was brought
to Argentina in 1852.
And it came with many
of the French varieties.
And actually, nobody
knows why Malbec
became the most important
variety in Argentina.
My theory is that it adapted
so well to the climate.
And I still think that Malbec
and Mendoza especially,
are such a great
combination, because Malbec
likes the sunlight, it
likes the kind of soils,
that I think that people
saw that it gave great wine.
And that's why they
kept on replanting it.
And if you actually think of the
climate of Argentina and Chile,
they are more different
than the climate
of Burgundy and Bordeaux.
Because we have these mountains.
And we have this high
altitude, semi-desert.
And they have the
ocean influence.
And they're much lower.
So actually, the
soil and the climate
are so different
that you would not
expect the same varieties to
do well in both countries.
So I think probably
what happened
is Carmenere did well there and
Malbec did well in Argentina.
And then that became
a historic fact.
But that's my theory.
I don't actually know
the for sure answer.
But great question-- I've
never been asked that before.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you have to make
reservations so far in advance
when you're in
Argentina than in Napa
and Chile and other places?
LAURA CATENA: OK.
So the question is why is the
reservation system so formal
in Argentina, and you have
to make reservations so far
in advance?
Did you have a hard time making
reservation at my winery?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
LAURA CATENA: You didn't get in?
You know, I'll
tell you one story.
I once got in a
taxi in Argentina.
And I asked the guy.
He didn't know who I was.
I said, where do you
take people wine tasting?
And he says, oh this
winery, that winery.
He's not mentioning my winery.
So I said, what
about Catena Zapata.
He said, oh I never
take them there.
It's impossible to get
an appointment there.
And so I go back to my guy.
And I say, open up more spots.
And actually we maximize
how many spots we have.
But I think what happens
is that everybody
goes at the same time.
So if you go during the peak,
Thanksgiving, Christmas,
the holidays here.
I don't know, when you go?
What time-- Christmas.
So what ends up-- first
of, all Argentines
don't like to work at Christmas.
So that might have
been a problem.
But even if you
go that week, they
get booked up so, so early.
Yeah, it is a problem.
Maybe there's not
enough wineries,
although there's
over 1,000 wineries.
But give me your name--
next time-- wait.
Anybody here, I have
this rule that anybody
who comes to my talk is VIP.
Especially somebody
who reads my book.
So if it's signed by me,
it's even more of a plus.
So you write to the winery.
And you say that
you met me, and I
said that you should get a tour.
And my email-- well, my email.
It's licatena@gmail.com.
You can write it down.
Or just say that I
gave you my email
and you lost it if you
can't write it down.
And you will get a tour.
OK.
So you just have to say that you
met me and you'll get a tour.
But I'm sorry that
that happened to you.
That's really sad for me.
I'm serious.
I hate it when
people tell me that.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: I was curious how
you feel about your winery's
interaction with say Wine
Spectator or other critics who
seem to fairly carefully control
who is successful and was not?
LAURA CATENA: Yeah.
So this is a big question in
wine about the wine critics.
And some people think
they have too much power.
Some people criticize
their kind of palates.
Some other people think
you can buy ratings.
Well, I can tell you for sure
that if you could buy ratings,
I would have been the first
one to try to buy one.
Sorry, but you can't.
You can't buy ratings.
You send your wines.
They taste them blind.
And I know people that
work at these magazines.
And they said it is
completely blind.
So it's-- I don't know why some
wines get rated higher than
others.
Hopefully it's the quality.
I do think that some reviewers
have certain palates.
And so you might do better
with a certain style.
But I don't think, like many
people say Robert Parker likes
huge oaky wines,
and I've actually
seen him review
highly some wines that
are very elegant and delicate.
So my view is there's--
consumers like ratings.
And for me as a
developing country,
I would have had a hard
time proving to anybody
that my wine was good
without these ratings.
So for us, they've
worked really well.
Does it seem unfair sometimes?
I'll taste a really great wine.
And it doesn't have
a great review.
And I feel like,
wow this I would
have given this wine 95 points.
And it got 85.
And if I were that wine
maker, I'd be pretty sad.
But for us, it's given
us this opportunity
to compete with the first world.
So-- and I can tell you that
these people are totally legit.
You cannot buy a score.
You send your wine.
They review it.
And we've got mostly
great reviews.
But we had a few bad reviews.
And my dad sends us all
kinds of emails when we do.
But thank you for that question,
very important question.
Yeah.
But in the end, I think you
should follow your own palate.
If you taste a wine
and you love it,
obviously ignore whatever
the reviewer said.
But if you find a reviewer
that shares your palate.
If you find that they generally
rate highly wines that you
like, then you might
want to follow them.
Especially if it's my wine.
OK.
Any other questions?
Everybody's desperate to drink.
We can keep on talking
about the wines.
Oh, so the wines we're
going to drink today,
we have the Catena
Alta chardonnay,
which comes from the
Adrianna vineyard.
We also have some
chardonnay planted there.
And I brought the
Adrianna Malbec,
which is a very
limited supply wine.
We only make between 200
and 300 cases of that wine.
So I had it actually shipped
specially for this tasting.
And then we are also
having the Catena Malbec,
which is more widely available.
And it's a blend of
different altitudes.
And it's really delicious.
And so I hope you
enjoy the tasting.
Was there another question?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
LAURA CATENA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So speaking
about blends,
would you agree that a blend is
when you get a wine blend, what
you're getting is kind of the
chemistry of the winemaker.
Like you're-- it's kind of
like going to a restaurant
for a cook.
LAURA CATENA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Because of the chef.
To chef, the way the chef
puts the meals together
and the foods.
And I've always liked blends.
And I'm wondering if that
has to do with the fact
that what you're experiencing
is the taste of the winemaker,
rather than the actual
purity of the varietal.
LAURA CATENA: That is
just an awesome question.
It's almost a half hour answer.
But I won't do a half hour.
So you can do blends within
a vineyard of different lots.
You can do altitude blend, which
is what the Catena Malbec is.
You can do blends
of many varieties.
So for example, in
many parts of France,
you're only allowed to
plant certain varieties.
So in Bordeaux, you can
only find five varieties.
And every wine from
Bordeaux is going
to be a blend of one
or five of those.
I think that traditional
blends like Bordeaux, people
spend 400 years planting
these different varieties
and figuring out what goes well.
So generally, a blend
is going to be a wine
that's very balanced
and that makes sense.
Because somebody spent a lot
of time making that wine.
And it might be a little
more elegant and smooth.
Sometimes though, it's fun to
try a single vineyard wine.
And you'll taste
the Adrianna, where
you get a little edginess.
And maybe it's not that perfect
of a wine, or not that smooth,
but it has a very
distinctive style.
So it's almost
like the difference
between wearing something
that looks really good
and wearing something crazy.
Both are good.
But it depends on what you like.
And I do think that in blends,
the winemaker's palate is key.
And one of things I tell
people about a family winery
is that the only
guarantee I can give you
is that my father and
I taste all the wines.
And we like to
drink what we make.
But I can't tell you the my wine
is better than my neighbor's.
I can only tell you that I
am making a wine that I like.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
Gracias.
[APPLAUSE]